有些年代平淡无奇，有些年代却浓缩了十年的巨变。过去九个月，我们见证了数十年的进步。如果你没意识到这一刻的份量，那才是真正的幻觉，是精神错乱。
如果突然有个精灵从瓶子里蹦出来说：“你想要什么都能实现”，谁会不欣喜若狂呢？你梦寐以求的每一个操作系统功能，它都能给你。大多五分钟搞定，有的需要
二十分钟。要是我们真的放开手脚，可能需要两个小时。我要最快的车，超速飞驰；我要能潜入马里亚纳海沟的潜水表；我要能在一分钟内装好的操作系统。
不到六十秒。我一直喜欢赛车的一点是，当我跌跌撞撞地从车里出来，筋疲力尽，头都抬不起来，躺在车库地板上，心里想：“天哪，我还活着。”
“我还活着。”机会之窗不会自己打开，它需要有人一点点冒险，一点点声誉的代价，一点点的阻力，一点点的批评，有时甚至是很大的声誉损失、很大的批评
或巨大的阻力。与所爱之人共同创造生命，绝对是地球上最巅峰的体验。以下是和大卫·海涅迈尔·汉森，也就是DHH的对话，他是Ruby on Rails的创始人，37 Signals的CTO，
新Amachi Linux操作系统的创造者，畅销书作家，赛车手，也是世界上最直言不讳、最多产的程序员之一。过去二十多年来，对他来说，编程意味着
精心手工打造优美的Ruby代码。但最近，自2025年末以来，DHH拥抱了AI革命，公开转型，再次成为最直言不讳、最多产的智能体工程师之一，尽管
他讨厌这个术语。所以，我们姑且称他们为实践者吧，无论编程正在变成什么形态——AI做大部分实际编程，而人类凭借高级设计愿景和品味掌舵。是的，DHH有时确实
有争议，但他总是无所畏惧、才华横溢，而且和他交谈很有趣。这又是一次激烈、开阔眼界、如过山车般的对话。这里是莱克斯·弗里德曼播客。为了支持它，请查看
描述中的赞助商，那里也有链接可以联系我、提问、反馈等等。现在，亲爱的朋友们，有请DHH。13个月前，我们坐在这里讨论编程，然后，呃，
一切都变了。那时你对AI在编程过程中的作用还有些怀疑，然后我们经历了智能体工程的迅猛发展。所以，简单来说，你对AI在编程中角色的看法是如何
改变的？你兴奋吗？恐惧吗？情绪像坐过山车吗？
我无比兴奋。
你说了很多关于乐趣的事。对我而言，存在主义的疑虑并不是情感上的，而只是理智上的。我的情感层面是百分之百纯粹的、毫不掩饰的喜悦，
乐观和惊叹，我们居然做到了让电脑做这些。我觉得很有趣的是，我们仅在13个月前就谈过话，因为感觉就像在不同的宇宙、不同的时代交谈。我喜欢这句话，我想是列宁说的：“有些年代
平淡无奇，而有些周却浓缩了数十年。”过去九个月，我们见证了数十年的进步。想象一下，当莱特兄弟首次飞行时你在场。昨天，《纽约时报》可能会写：“还要一万年我们才能飞。”
然后第二天，我们就飞上了天，几年后就有跨大西洋的飞机了。整个世界彻底改变了。能见证那样的时刻是多么幸运。
如果你放眼整个人类历史，有多少人能在自己出生的时代里经历这样的变革？他们从未见过世界和社会的彻底改变。而我有幸经历了两次这样的变革，
这让我感到无比荣幸。我见证过互联网的兴起，
从互联网前到互联网后，而现在又是AI前到AI后。多么精彩的旅程。多么幸运。
是的。但关键是，这感觉像是人类历史上最快的变化。所以我想大概是在十二月，也可能十一月末，
十一月24日。
你知道，就像世界大战中一个国家入侵另一个国家那样，这也是我们谈论AI改变一切的方式。是的，它确实改变了许多优秀开发者，他们
从AI做简单的自动补全、大概编写5%到10%到15%到20%的代码，转变到编写80%的代码。
或者百分之百。
是啊，百分之百，尤其是如果不是面向公众的产品。
对我来说，即使回顾一年前的对话，我现在的观点其实没变，还是一年前的那些想法。当初我不喜欢AI的那种模式，就是自动补全或者AI聊天机器人那种。
AI聊天机器人模式。不过，那个聊天机器人我其实挺喜欢的，正如我们聊过的，一开始就是个很好的导师，上网查资料也是很棒的方式，它不是用来替代我写代码的。然后，我们迎来了智能体。
是啊，智能体一开始只是五分钟的新鲜玩意儿，然后变得惊人，然后就是‘天哪，这是不是AI啊’，这一切都发生在去年，甚至就在最近几个月内，我们这里就出现了这几个面孔。
我们有了前智能体时代的AI，我当时挺兴奋的，但它并没有从根本上改变游戏规则，没有完全改变我的工作方式。我还在凿代码，只是多了一个小帮手，一个小伙伴，我可以和他交流想法。
我可以和他碰撞想法，也可以更高效地查找网上信息等等。这只是让我做以往的事情更高效一些，并没有改变我对电脑的情感联系。
电脑。然后我们到了2025年11月24日。对我而言，Opus 4.5是一个分水岭，我并没有在24号那天就试它，好像是26号试的。我给了它几个任务，然后意识到输出的质量高得惊人，几乎就像我自己写的一样。
它输出得和我写的惊人地接近。我记得自己往后一靠，心想：刚才发生了什么？
我们是怎么从夏天跟你聊的那个自动补全的烂摊子，几个月后就变成这样的？我们怎么同时实现了智能提升和可用性提升？这个智能体框架的问题，我不知道Opus 4.5是否比我们夏天用的Opus 4聪明很多，但它在操作你的电脑、使用工具、检查自己的工作、这样应用智能方面，让你能得到真正有意义的工作成果，那完全不同了。
我不知道Opus 4.5是否比我们夏天用的Opus 4聪明很多，但它在操作你的电脑、使用工具、检查自己的工作，并且以这种方式应用智能，让你能够从中获得真正有意义的工作成果，那是完全不同的。
可以得到真正有意义的工作，这几乎对所有在圣诞假期关注并开始玩它的人来说都是一个巨大的变化。我所听到的是这样的。
从Shopify和其他地方，有很多员工。
突然有了喘息的机会，突然有几周时间可以放松一下，看看发生了什么，然后试一试，就有了同样令人惊叹的体验，这些智能体和我们之前见到的完全不一样了。然后我们进入到了这个阶段。
到这个时候我已经很兴奋了。到了12月，我已经在重新审视我所有的先入之见，想着，‘哇，如果它能做这个，那它能不能也做那个？’
哦，是的，它可以。
而且，Opus 4.5现在看起来像个模型了。
对。
这就是进步的魔力，你以为你达到某个目标了。我记得当时想，如果这是我们得到的最后一个模型，我就满足了，我会很高兴。我可以用Opus 4.5度过接下来的20年，你不会听到我任何抱怨，因为它实在是太棒了。
从我这里，因为它实在太出色了。
看到一个智能体以我想要的方式完成所有工作，真是太神奇了。这不仅仅是因为它能解决任务，还因为我可以看着它的路径说：‘是的，是的。嗯，也许不是那里，但差不多’，而且它会给你一些备注，你会到达我想去的地方，以我想要的方式到达。它能产出我想合并的代码，能产出看起来漂亮的代码，如果它用Ruby写的（Rust另说），但智能体真正成为我工作方式的延伸，这种能力真是太新颖了。
它会给你一些备注，你会到达我想去的地方，以我想要的方式到达。它能产出我想合并的代码，能产出看起来漂亮的代码，如果它用Ruby写的（Rust另说），但智能体真正成为我工作方式的延伸，这种能力真是太新颖了。
智能体真正成为我工作方式的延伸，这种能力非常新颖，但接着我们等到初春，突然就有了子智能体。有了能够细分任务的框架，原本需要Opus花不少时间的事情，突然只需要五分之一或十分之一的时间，因为它可以被分解，突然你有了八个子智能体为你工作。
像Opus要花不少时间的事情，突然只需要五分之一或十分之一的时间，因为它可以被分解，突然你有了八个子智能体为你工作。但在我看来，智能体时代的这两个初始阶段，仍然需要我自己来‘开车’。
开车。我可以告诉它我想要什么，去哪里找，然后在它跑偏时稍微纠正一下，然后我们就能到达目的地，我会快很多，但我必须坐在驾驶座上。我必须告诉它我想要什么，而且我必须成为那个...
审查者，也就是输出的审计者。然后终于，在这个夏天，随着Opus 5、Fable和Soul，GPT Soul，以及在一定程度上一些开放权重模型的问世，我们进入了一个新时代，我不再告诉它我们要去哪里。
而是告诉它我遇到的问题，告诉它我模糊的想法。它告诉我该往哪里走。
它告诉我该走哪条路。我仍然会去查看，因为我是一个好奇的人，我喜欢电脑，也喜欢它产生的结果。但我真的不必须看了。在生成代码和选择路径的过程中，我已经变得可有可无。
记得早期GPS系统刚出来的时候吗？
它们相比看地图已经神奇多了，但你仍然需要保持注意力。它会把你开进海里吗？我记得那些报纸文章说GPS很糟糕，因为人们不注意，结果开进了海里。
现在GPS把人开进海里是什么时候的事了？这种事已经不会再发生了。事实上，现在汽车都能自动驾驶了，对吧？所以我们现在达到的程度是，我可以在我现在工作的领域信任它。
在我目前工作的领域，我可以信任它，并完全确信它会支持我。它不会做蠢事。即使做了蠢事，它也能自己恢复。
我们应该提到，程序员工作的领域有很多种。有——
实际上我不太清楚，但我觉得开发中最常见的领域就像网页开发的增删改查。你有一个数据库，有一个面向用户的界面，然后它来回做一些操作，可以是内部使用，从单人到多人，
或者是少数人，或者面向全世界。我认为对于这种领域，你确实可以实现100%由AI编写代码，而且如果你是一个优秀的程序员，对幕后发生的事情有很好的直觉，
那么你真的可以不看代码。至少我的经验是这样的。我不知道你需要多少编程经验才能凭直觉知道系统是否在幕后正常运行，
通过观察系统的涟漪效应和症状来直觉判断，但我觉得对于这个领域，接近100%。然后还有一些你也在操作的领域，比如编写一个Linux发行版。
那里可能需要更多关注，因为你痴迷于速度之类的东西。也许你需要多看一点代码。然后还有安全关键系统，一直到操作核电站或自动驾驶汽车。
比如核电站或自动驾驶汽车。也许你需要更仔细地查看代码。
是的。但尽管如此，AI在发现和修复安全漏洞方面能力非常强。
这就是Fable引起轰动的原因。这个模型发现漏洞的能力太强了，攻击者可以利用它，所以发布它根本不安全。讽刺的是，当你看到那个领域时，
似乎我们已经达到了几乎无人能及的水平，因为许多安全漏洞涉及组合技。你在这里发现一个小漏洞，单独来看可能不是最严重的问题，
但当你把它和其他四个组合起来，突然你就有了RCE（远程命令执行）。能做到这一点的人类非常罕见。他们通常在国家资助的组织或其他秘密行动中工作。
不是随便在外面找漏洞的人。所以他们在这方面已经非常擅长了。Linux发行版也是我100%使用AI的原因，因为过去三个月我一直在开发Umachi，这个版本
几天前刚发布，叫Quattro。几乎从开始开发那个版本起，AI代理的加速就接近100%。而在过去两个月里，它达到了100%。我没有手写
真的
Quattro中发布的任何代码。我审查了所有代码的结构。我审查了系统模型层中任何关键部分的每一行。
而且我没有看很多UI代码。我没有看很多辅助代码，也没有手写任何新功能。但之后，网页部分，实际上涉及Basecamp和Hey我们的专业产品，用户很多，代码库相对较大，完全用AI代理加速被证明出乎意料地棘手。
我们不久前刚发布了Basecamp 5。那是37signals的第一个真正由AI代理加速的产品，因为我们从二月左右就进入了最后的冲刺阶段。到那时，AI代理已经很好了。
当时我们处于二月左右的最后冲刺阶段。那时AI代理已经很强了。
嗯嗯。
我们曾有过一段早期热潮，觉得这问题解决了：我们可以让设计师直接编程。他们知道自己想要什么功能，知道想让它成为什么样子。就让他们自由发挥吧。然后我们就让他们自由发挥了。
是啊，结果我们收到了一大堆拉取请求，单个看也许在当时还说得过去，但合在一起就把系统架构给毁了。最后我们不得不手动清理，靠人工一点一点地收拾残局。
亲手把它恢复成结构协调、连贯一致的样子。所以我们还留有余悸。顺便说一句，那是在二月份。现在情况已经大不一样了。
等等，那我们从中学到了什么？其中一个教训是不是说，在这个阶段，你必须得是个程序员才能玩转vibe coding？
才能对现有的大型代码库进行vibe coding，哪怕是CRUD应用，如果想保留让系统发展到今天的架构精髓。这也是我一直强调的一点：当有人指责vibe
编码者是垃圾生成器时，我会反唇相讥：“你们有没有看过普通程序员的产出？”那也是另一种垃圾。如果你看过许多大公司幕后，想想他们的代码库
经过3000个人之后是什么样的，那简直糟透了。你能告诉我你直觉上的看法吗？我像是退后一步观察我们依赖的各种应用。比如Adobe Photoshop这类
东西。看起来那边的开发进展并没有加速。为什么？你能从Basecamp这样成熟、用户量巨大的产品中总结出什么经验？为什么我们没看到这些成熟应用在更新、功能上
出现超级快速的增长呢？原因有很多。我先说最关键的。一旦需要人类团队协作，瓶颈往往不是在实现上。
而是人的带宽和沟通。当有一个产品经理、几个设计师、他们上头的副总裁，再上面还有CTO，每个人都想参与塑造过程，因为大家都在证明自己存在的价值。
生产力就是在这里被消耗殆尽的。我在过去三个月开发Amachi时领悟到，要获得那种神奇的10倍、100倍，甚至少数情况1000倍的生产力提升，你必须直接和智能体协作，不能
靠另一个人来中转这种带宽，实在太慢了。一方面，这确实有点遗憾。我的意思是，我喜欢人类，一起工作很棒，但这也意味着我们需要调整预期
关于这些智能体能做什么。如果是人类在驱动，加上大公司里的三层审批和其他机制，实施部分只是其中一小块。另外我想说的是
大多数组织根本不知道自己想要什么，不知道怎么改进。他们的瓶颈不在于实施，而在于创意、愿景和品味。
如果你的实施能力超过了这些要素的储备，那也没用。你可以让很多烂主意变成现实，那你打算发布什么呢？听起来像是微软的产物。那不是
我们想在这里复制的。这个过程其实不是——因为我们早就有了。如果你退一步想想那些拥有数万名程序员的大公司。
我这是在拿微软开涮。我有时喜欢微软，但这次要挑刺，因为他们拥有无尽的资源和数十年无限制的编程能力，对吧？这恰恰说明，仅仅能写
大量代码并不能产生伟大而有吸引力的软件。另一个事实是，这种能力我们才拥有大约6个月，在人类生命周期中，内化这种变化的时间并不长。而且我认为
很有趣的是，对AI的批评却是“为什么不能更快一点？”
嗯。
你在说什么？我们还没有任何其他形式的进步能像AI这么快。你不耐烦是因为在过去三个月里，我们还没有重写整个世界，把它变成一个软件完美的乌托邦。
你基本上是在说每个人都应该切换到Linux。现在，一个论点是我们可以重写Linux上缺失的所有软件。Linux多年来一直是我一生的挚爱，但其中一个
我仍然依赖Windows甚至Mac的原因是因为视频编辑，比如Premiere。
我们会解决这个问题的。但是
所以问题是，谁会为Linux打造Premiere和Photoshop？感觉现在一个人就能做到了。
百分之百，一个人就能做到。而且，我，我可以不耐烦。事实上，我或者其他任何人，
不耐烦是亲自动手的第一步，对吧？
没错。而且有成千上万的社区成员使用Adobe Premiere或Da Vinci等非线性视频编辑器，
他们都了解这些挫败感。每个人都能感同身受。你可以看看Reddit，看看论坛，大家都知道。呃，我不知道具体是什么。可能是管理问题，可能是会议，那些你一直讨论的，
那些公司内部的官僚作风，拖慢了所有事情，包括功能的开发。但感觉如果让一些开发者带着一群代理放手去干，
一切都能解决。但再说，根据你所说的一切，也许方法就是从头开始，也许通过开源或者有人创立新公司。而在大公司内部，现在很难通过让开发者自由构建来加速进入代理时代。
这是经典的创新者困境。这些公司在旧方式上太过成功和根深蒂固，因此它们的整个结构、管理层、流程都是为一个已不存在的时代调校的。
但你无法转向。这些是超级油轮，做不到。这就是我们终于看到科技行业出现这种颠覆的原因。有一段时间，我对苹果和谷歌在移动领域的双头垄断感到非常不满，因为感觉移动是我们最重要的计算平台。
这让我看不到推翻谷歌或苹果的可能性，它们占据顶端，控制一切，收取过路费。
但游戏变了。这不再是最重要的平台。手机很重要，但还有很多其他形态的设备出现，比如眼镜、耳机等什么都有。现在一切都有可能。
但计算平台本身可能40年来第一次受到了挑战。看看桌面端，Linux从91年就存在了，但没有在桌面上流行或取代。它占领了其他所有领域。
你桌上的所有设备，冰箱，烤面包机，都运行Linux，除了你的电脑。现在有趣的是，你的Android实际上是Linux，但被包装得让你认不出来。
但现在有个突破口。正如你所说，如果有一个绑定你到Windows的软件，你个人完全可以开始重写它。
也许你无法覆盖100%的功能，但有个关于Microsoft Office的老笑话：我只用了5%。是啊，但我们每个人都用了不同的5%。那如果我们各自构建自己的5%呢？
如果我只取我需要的功能来实现呢？那是一个完全不同的挑战，而代理现在就能做得很好，而且我已经多次这样做了。所以，在最新的agent gauge中，我发现一个神奇的事情：
我成为了一个多语言程序员，这绝对是我以前不是的。我首先是Ruby程序员，然后涉猎了一点bash。
是的。在过去的两个月里，我写了C++，我写了三个应用程序，已经在Omachi Quattro中发布了。
我写了一个写作应用。我之前用Topora，一个很好的应用，它基于另一个应用IA Writer，那是我的最爱，在Mac上用于干净简洁的Markdown写作环境，我所有文章都是在那里写的。
然后我转到Linux，无法使用IA Writer。所以我转向了Tapora，一个共享软件，功能很多但我不需要。大约六、七周前，我想：
你知道吗？我只需要Tapora的5%，它本身已经很基础了。我直接告诉代理开始，用C++和Qt编写，因为它会与Quattro的美学契合。
大约20分钟内，就有第一个版本我开始用了。一开始不太对。但两天内，我就放弃了Tapora，从那时起，我所有文章都是在Amarite中写的。
我能就某事请教你的意见和远见吗？我发现，使用代理，你可以写出像Tapora的替代品，完全个性化定制你的需求。
对。只为一个用户考虑，然后会有版本从单一用户扩展到更广泛的受众。实际上，我写了很多软件仅为自己，我发现这样更容易，也能更好地完成我的事情。
例如，我写了一个视频编辑器，只为自己用就很容易。
对，我从来没有——不像你——做过那种被大量人使用的东西，我觉得那有点吓人，让人心里发怵。所以在这个智能体时代，你怎么跨出那一步，去真正解决你自己的问题，同时又把它扩展成对别人也有用的东西呢？我觉得这种构建方式很美。
就像你说的，为自己而建是很美的，但怎么同时让它对别人也有用？你有没有什么建议？而且你有没有看到那种问题，就是给自己建个工具太容易了？
有，但没你想的那么复杂。等你给自己建好一个工具，你只要告诉你的智能体把它放到GitHub上就行。
对，
别的都不用做。它会自己搞定怎么把仓库放到GitHub上，还会写个漂亮的README，开始用GitHub的发布功能来跟踪更新。它其实能比你更好地维护软件，
因为它比你有耐心得多，也勤快得多，干那些维护开源软件琐碎的事情，比你在行多了。
然后你就可以尽情享受使用你自己做的软件的乐趣，想怎么改进就怎么改进。这就引出了我们开源界争论很久的一个大问题：AI的贡献对维护者来说是好事还是坏事？现在有很多维护者挺不爽的，因为他们突然收到大量Pull Request，来自那些可能根本不算好程序员、甚至压根不是程序员的人。
很多维护者很恼火，突然涌进来一大堆Pull Request，贡献者可能技术不怎么样，甚至根本不会编程。
朝他们的软件涌来。我一看这争论，就想说你开什么玩笑？这明明是一股白送的贡献，你想收就收，不想收就拉倒，你倒抱怨起它存在了。这听起来就像‘我的牛排太嫩了，龙虾黄油太多了’——你有什么好抱怨的？这是最棒的事了！这就是我们长久以来宣称的开源魔力，每个人都来贡献。但当然，从来都没实现过。
这纯粹是无病呻吟。你抱怨啥呢？这简直太棒了！这不就是我们长期以来宣扬的开源的神奇之处吗？——人人都能贡献。
我们鼓吹了那么久的开源的魔力，本该如此。但显然从来不是这么回事。只有一小撮人真正贡献开源，都是那些技术高超的巫师。
技术高超的巫师。所以说现在有点像宗教改革时刻。我们和电脑之间本来有中间人，就是那帮神职人员一样的程序员。现在突然他们被去中介化了，就像路德在1500年代把《九十五条论纲》钉在门上一样。其中很明显一条就是关于中介的：你应该直接接触到高等智慧。
这正是路德在1500年代钉在门上的《九十五条论纲》之一，就是关于去中介化的——你应该直接接触更高智能。而且，这类“神职人员”的中间层正在被剥掉。
但你不还是需要那些“巫师”来保证代码库的高标准吗？
百分之百需要。这也是开源界一直以来的现实。第二个让我恼火的论点，就是你说的这个。我运营开源项目25年了，真的看过成千上万程序员写出来的东西。我觉得我有统计基础敢断言：大多数程序员————他们真不行。
我看过几千甚至上万程序员的产出。我觉得我有统计基础来断言：大部分程序员——他们真的很烂。我停顿了一下，不是那个意思，我是指他们写不出我想要的那种代码。
意思是他们写不出我想要的代码；他们的bug报告里没有所有相关信息；他们的Pull Request不解释为什么；他们懒得写必要的代码注释。
他们不复查自己的工作；不写单元测试；不做好创建好软件所需的那些事情。但你知道谁会做吗？智能体——只要你告诉它们。它们绝大多数时候非常勤恳地执行你的指令，有时甚至过了头。
它们经常一丝不苟地照你说的做，有时甚至过头。但这实际上意味着，如果你拿普通程序员和他们的Pull Request，来和普通开源项目比，他们已经被智能体超越了。我宁愿收到一个智能体写给我的项目的Pull Request，也不要人类写的。
我更愿意收到智能体给我的项目写的Pull Request，而不是人类写的。这不仅是因为质量更好，还因为我拒绝的时候心里没那么愧疚。反正又不是你写的。我可以看看你的智能体替你写了什么，然后说“哎，不要”。
我可以就看看你的智能体写的什么，然后说不要。这在开源界一直如此。我还觉得这其实是开源维护者的毛病之一：他们太有爱心和神经质了，总把任何贡献都当成自己必须倾尽全力让它合并进代码库的义务。根本不是那么回事。
他们太有“博爱”精神，潜意识里要求自己对任何贡献都负有义务，要尽一切可能将其合入代码。完全不是这样。你完全可以说不，甚至更好的是，你可以说“不用，谢谢”。
说“不用了，谢谢”就行。如果你能意识到你的项目可以按你的愿景和路线图来存在和发展，那么在智能体时代，拒绝你不要的贡献就容易多了，因为你连一个人的感情都不用伤害，只是拒绝一个“铁家伙”而已。那个机器也不会在意。
你拒绝你不想要的贡献时，根本不会打扰或伤害到任何人——只是拒了个“机器人”，它也绝不会介意。事实上，那些制造“机器人”的实验室，就喜欢你把token白白花掉——反正他们照收钱。
它们照样收费。所以，在我看来，现在是成为开源软件维护者最好的时代。我们不仅有大量的、高品质的智能体Pull Request，而且每一步都有保障。我们
同时，我们也能利用那些以前无法参与项目的人的创造力。
我运行Zomachi项目已经一年多了，在最近三个月里，我在Quattro上合并了一千多个拉取请求。其中很多请求都来自那些不算是传统程序员的人，或者是在其他领域工作的程序员，而不是Linux操作系统或发行版开发的专家。他们能通过智能体贡献好主意，而我可以从中挑选最好的。
不是传统程序员或来自其他领域的程序员，而非Linux操作系统或发行版开发的专业人士。他们之所以能贡献自己的好点子，正是因为有了智能体，而我得以从中择优录取。
嗯。
因为那些想法就在那里，否则它们只会留在人们的脑海中。再说一次，这不是开源的目的吗？我们要汇聚整个星球的集体智慧和创造力，并将其投入到让我们都能受益的项目中去。
把那些想法引向一个我们都受益的共同体，汇聚每个人的努力。
目前Omachy上有大约400个未合并的拉取请求，比一周前翻了一番。可见加速是真实的，工具也在进步。我已经不再逐个审查拉取请求了，好一阵子没这么做了。我让智能体帮我审查它们。
我现在已经不怎么审查了，而是让智能体代劳。
然后他们会给我总结，告诉我哪些可以进入决策阶段，由人类来做决定：该合并还是不该合并？
我不需要再看那些错误、重复或糟糕的拉取请求。智能体可以替我筛选掉这些糟粕。我只需要看那些真正有价值的部分——即将实施的好主意，以及智能体在虚拟机里替我验证过的缺陷修复。
所有复现和管理开源项目的琐事正在以闪电般的速度消失，剩下的都是精华和核心，也就是软件开发中最关键的人文决策——应该做什么，未来往哪个方向走。
你认为那些好主意的核心最终都源于人类头脑吗？比如，个人贡献者能否被智能体替代，还是说每个拉取请求的改进实质上都需要人类的创意？是不是可能全都交由智能体处理？这是我在第一个智能体时代（2014年11月到28年2月）思考的问题。
实际上，像如何改进Omachy这样源源不断的请求，每一个之所以存在，正是因为背后有人的创意。还是说，这一切都可以由一群智能体来完成？这便是我在第一个智能体时代（2014年11月至2018年2月）里所思考和采用的模式。
嗯。
我以为所有想法都会源自人类。他们会告诉智能体要做什么，然后智能体就去执行。
嗯。【清嗓子】
我完全不认为那是事实。我见过你们无法置信的事物。模型产出的想法之精彩，让我这个自以为擅长创意的人感到谦卑。智能体具备令人惊叹的创新思维。
而那些仍然坚持智能体只是复读机的人，其实还固守着旧观念。
说他们在重复已有想法，那是他们对过去半年来进展的幻觉。你可能会说，DHH又得“AI精神病”了。
嗯，你能为自己辩护一下吗？说明你并非真的处于幻觉状态，就像《飞越疯人院》那样？并反驳这种说法？
我确实有些发烧，但这是因为我从事计算机工作四十年，而过去两个月里我见到的一切是前所未有的。
是啊，我整个职业生涯乃至人生，都致力于对计算机的热爱，并主要投入在工作中。如今，这一切突然被颠覆，彻底改写。我自然会感到炽热。谁见到这个现实而不为之兴奋呢？
如果你没有感到兴-奋，至少也应该激动。其实，或许反过来才对。如果你没能意识到这一刻的重要性，那才是幻觉、才是病态。真正的病态在于认为世界几乎没有变化。
我们只是有一些电子鹦鹉在面前复述。在我看来，有人提出这种论点，是因为他们看不到进步的成果。这正好说明你之前的观点。
你之前问道：出色的软件在哪里？为什么美国GDP没有同比增长12%？首先，得给点时间。才过了一年而已，老天！【笑声】其次，我自己就能感受到。
我其实带来了那个布丁。
嗯，Quattro 在周五发布了，已经被成千上万人下载。
而且他们喜欢它，非常喜欢。虽然去查一下 Perplexity 可能会说 Amachi 是一个高度主观的基于 Arch Linux 的桌面发行版，围绕 Hyperland Whan 平铺合成器，由 David 创建。
Hynamire Hansen 也就是 DHH，把它开发成一个精致的开发者工作站，有着统一的视觉风格，并且预配置了许多日常工具。
让我这么说吧，Umachi 是一个漂亮、现代且主观的 Linux 系统，是 Mac OS 和 Windows 的替代品，而且它简直太棒了。
Quattro 这个东西，嗯，你是在推动代理时代的到来。
对，这是我们刚发布的最新版本，这也有点有趣。Umachi 项目刚成立一年多一点点。我是去年夏天在洛杉矶 24 小时耐力赛的间隙开始的。
是的，在那里我看了很多关于 Linux 崛起的 YouTube 视频，结果就上头了。然后开始做我第二次尝试创建更好 Linux 操作系统的迭代。第一次迭代我们上次聊过。
那叫 Amakoup，它基于现有的 Ubuntu 系统，还行。但对于新版本，我能投入的野心是完全不同的，因为我在技术栈上深入了七层。尽管如此，那仍然是。
在一个没有代理的世界里完成的。一开始我手动写了所有的基本脚本，然后我看到了中途发生的转变。
我做了几版 Omachi，有部分代理加速，然后三个月前。
就全速前进了，100% 的东西由代理编写，但由我来掌控。嗯。
结果这成了一种非常不同的体验，也构建了一个非常不同的操作系统，因为我的野心仿佛突然没有了上限。
嗯。
我可以看到 Windows、Mac 或其他 Linux 系统上的任何功能，然后说，我想要那个，代理就会实现。所以我想要的一切都突然触手可及，这让我有点疯狂了。
谁会不疯狂呢？如果突然有一个精灵从瓶子里冒出来说："你想要什么都可以。你在操作系统里梦想过的每一个功能，我都能带给你。大多数在 5 分钟内，少数需要 20 分钟。"
如果我们真的大干一场，也只要两小时。
你看过电影《梦之安魂曲》吗？这里有一种像毒品一样的效果。是的。
我个人觉得，我们会从多个层面探讨这个问题，但这种突然赋予我们的力量实在太大了，很难知道该怎么办，就像指环王里的霍比特人一样。我发现自己。
真的被多任务压得喘不过气来，几乎要崩溃了。对很多事情超级兴奋，但回过头来，你只想专注于一件事，真正地交付成果。
我没有那种感觉，没有被压倒，没有恐惧，没有扭曲，因为我有使命（清喉咙）。
我有明确的方向，所以我能把所有这些新力量用于一个单一目标和结果：创造完美的电脑。因此，我对 AI 的所有探索都为此服务。当然我也有日常工作。
我们那儿也用代理，也是为了实现特定目标。但通过 Yachi 的体验，我可以直接深入我的大脑，增加从想法到软件实现的带宽。
就像从拨号上网直接升级到高速宽带一样。
说到带宽，我想你在播客里采访埃隆时，他谈到过人体带宽的问题，Neuralink和其他项目正试图提升这个带宽。我们现在交流的带宽其实很低，因为我们
受限于认知和说话速度。但是当你协调一群智能体工作时，就不会受到这些限制。不过我得先说明，如果九个月前听到自己这样说话，
我可能会给自己贴上“AI妄想症”的标签。这么说挺合适，因为九个月前这么说的人还没做出什么实际成果。我觉得这是根本区别——有些人
很早就看到了这个趋势。其实我入局不算早，之前还相当怀疑，虽然也用过一些AI，但我不是第一个下载Claude Code的人。我记得Boris是在
二月底发布的，而我大概到九月才装。所以在那大约六个月里，先驱们已经瞥见了未来的苗头，但那时还不成熟，因为智能不够，
工具也不够好，但他们能看到那些微光，而我不能。托比——Shopify的CEO，也是我现在在Omachi项目上的搭档——他也被这种想法给感染了。他看得很早，而且
试图告诉我这些，但我看不到，我无法理解他看到的东西。
当时你是个唱反调的人。
对，我当时还停留在地球上。
好的。
而他已经登上火箭飞向太空了。我记得读过他给公司写的关于AI的备忘录，当时觉得有点夸张。
感觉你把一件我还没法感觉到实处的事情说得太重要了，
因为这些东西在哪呢？我试着用了一下，它写的代码我不喜欢，还老想打断我。你这些想法是从哪来的？
所以，我理解，完全理解。如果你没见过现在这种智能水平能产出的东西，你当然会觉得说那些话的人有点疯癫。因为到目前为止，你的所有经验都在告诉你
他们就是疯了。因为回顾过去四五十年计算机编程的历史，一直有人在承诺说普通人只要说话就能编程，会有什么第四代语言。
Lisp曾经被这样宣传过，Smalltalk也被誉为能让普通人编写自己应用的环境，但除了Microsoft Access数据库或Excel之外，
那些都只是终端用户编程环境，根本没法跟现在相比。而且我说的不是终端用户，而是像我这样有25年编程经验的人，看到这些产出和
加速过程以及质量，然后真的发布出去。我认为这很快就会彻底改变整个讨论。少数还在观望、拿不定主意的人，他们还困在
2025年初那个关于“机械鹦鹉”的梗里，他们很快就会被扑面而来的证据淹没。所以我希望看到像Omachi这样的项目，真的展示出“智能体优先”的理念。
这种趋势正在来临，一切都近在眼前。
在我之前提到的那些看似不起眼的领域，比如视频编辑、像Typora这样的应用，
是的，
这类东西都会变。
这些都会发生，我已经看到了一些早期的迹象。Omachi的一个很酷的特点是它有更强大的插件系统，你可以通过创建自己的插件来扩展操作系统，甚至重新定义
用户界面、面板和功能，这些插件可以通过克隆我们内置的工具来创建。比如说，你想要一个不同的日历，Omachi自带了日历，你只需点击
一个小时钟，会弹出日历，但它不支持iCal，比如不能导入你的日程。这样的应用已经有大约17个了。而在三天之内，Omachi插件市场上就有了330个插件。我从来没见过
任何我参与过的项目有这种增长速度。我从未见过这么广泛的参与。我从未见过这么多人能够创造对自己有意义、同时对别人也快速可用的软件。
这一切都因为Omachi提供了一组技能，告诉任何智能体如何为操作系统创建扩展，从而让你看到真正可塑性的愿景。我差点要说“智能体化”，我讨厌那个词。
我讨厌这个词的部分原因是，首先它已经变成了营销废话，到处乱贴。
我希望有个不同的词，就表示AI做事。
“氛围编程”感觉也不对。
没错，因为“氛围编程”在我看来就像21世纪初的“脚本小子”，下载人家写的PHP脚本，自己什么都不懂就拿来用。而虽然这在某种意义上是对的，包括我自己“氛围编程”的项目，就像我提到的，我用C++写过东西，也用Rust写过。
”氛围编程“的项目，包括我自己的，我写过C++，也写过Rust。
嗯哼。
Rust，我恨透了Rust。对我来说，看到Rust代码就像眼睛里倒硫酸。
为什么，为什么你恨Rust？
在我看来，Rust可能是过去40年里发明的最丑的编程语言。所以它和Rails正好相反。
是相反。但是
你写过它。
我用Rust写过应用，因为Rust的输出确实惊艳。内存安全、作为系统语言、高效，这些都不可思议。所以对我来说，Rust可以既是对人类消费最令人厌恶的编程语言，又是智能体工程的绝佳平台。这两个事实在我脑子里可以共存。
（接上）最令人厌恶的编程语言，但同时是智能体工程的绝佳平台，这两个事实可以轻松共存。
你觉得有没有可能，我们直接把“智能体工程”叫做编程？我们能不能改变编程的含义？因为几个月后，谁还会用老方法编程呢？
我觉得我们不应该复用那个术语，因为对我来说，编程意味着理解某些基本概念：循环、条件、变量，编程语言的所有结构，这些才构成编程本身，
而不是创造程序。因为在智能体时代之前，你可以说CEO在编程，他雇了一堆程序员，告诉他们做什么，然后软件就出来了，可以卖。
我不认为大多数人会叫那个CEO为程序员。我也不认为我们应该把“氛围编程者”叫做程序员。“氛围编程”，如果在这里定义，就是让智能体给你造软件，你不看实现细节。
我认为这就是“氛围编程”和编程的区别。或者说是智能体加速开发。但你不觉得，稍微反驳一下，你不觉得一个老派程序员做智能体工程和非程序员做智能体工程是不同的吗？我的意思是，如果你知道for循环是什么，知道函数式编程是什么，知道软件工程的一些基本原则，
你做基于自然语言的智能体工程会不同且更有系统性，而你能构建的东西的规模和种类会比“氛围编程”者大得多。
（接上）软件工程的基本原理，你做自然语言的智能体工程方式会不同，会更系统化，能构建的规模更大，种类更多。
为了论证，我稍微扩展一下话题。实际上我觉得有一段时间，我对编程懂得多反而是个劣势，因为我指示智能体按我规定的方式做事，它们很擅长这样，在头一个“智能体时刻”（我们别叫它时代，那只是持续了三个月的时刻），在头一个“智能体时刻”，我觉得非常高效，我...
（接上）我让它们按我规定的方式做，它们很擅长，在最初的智能体时刻，感觉生产效率很高，我...
通过告诉AI智能体该做什么，就像我自己会做的那样，反而能获得更高的生产力。我运用了自己作为程序员的所有经验来做这件事。
然后我在下一个阶段有点迟到了，那个阶段允许任何人向智能体描述结果或问题，从而获得比程序员规定路径更好的解决方案。明白吗？
好吧，我们在这儿争论得挺有意思的。那你是不是在暗示，有些问题上，非程序员反而比程序员更擅长使用AI呢？
百分之百肯定。
我这么说的原因，让我在这儿定义清楚。很多程序员并不是好的产品经理。软件其实就是产品管理。它应该做什么？为谁做？
怎么做？应该是什么样子？我们的优先级是什么？我们先从什么开始？第一版包含哪些功能？所有这些技能并不是每个程序员都能轻松掌握或平均分配的。在AI代理时代，当你让智能体去执行时，这些才是你需要的技能。
让智能体和AI去做实现，这些才是你需要的技能。而我恰好两边的经验都有，这也是为什么我热爱这个时代。我仍然能活在那个看着完整实现的老世界里，因为有些领域我觉得那仍然有价值，
而且我也活在未来。正如我所说，当我创建Omarchy时，我一行C++代码都没看。我特意对自己说，这是一场实验。
我把它当作一个纯粹的黑盒实验。我会像任何其他用户一样，对他们数字打字机的工作方式有自己的看法，就像其他类型的作者对软件如何运作有看法一样，这算是个公平的实验。
就像视频编辑者，他们清楚地知道不喜欢Adobe Premiere的哪些地方，以及如何改进，但他们没有能力去改进它。
他们缺乏改进的能力。嗯。
怎么会这样？
但我要反驳一下，我认为程序员擅长的是系统性设计，比如像做系统一样思考，讲究严谨性。
是的。我认为现在以及未来很长一段时间，即使是基于自然语言控制智能体系统，也需要一定的严谨性。不是过度结构化的严谨，而是要非常具体地说明
嗯，系统的目标，如何验证，想做哪类安全测试等等这些。但再反驳一下，系统应该够聪明。
六个月前我也会这么说，而且那时候这样说是对的。但自从近几周通过智能体加速开发Machi以来，我发现很多时候我不得不承认，智能体比我更懂。
我有自知之明，知道智能体懂得更多。你真的可以说：‘确保它安全。’
没错，它比我们更清楚这包含哪些内容。你现在笑了，但这是真的。实际上，
天哪，
一个好的类比就是智能体MD/云MD文件。
曾经有个热门时刻，大家都在疯狂微优化那个。比如‘你告诉智能体这个，告诉那个’，最后你得到了一大堆让智能体执行的指令文件。
在Claude Code工作的Boris最近接受采访时提到Opus 5，他们为Opus 5（可能还有Fable）提供的系统提示词缩减了80%，因为智能体不仅不需要那么多人类指令，事实上
过于指令化的人类反而会损害它的表现。任何经历过外行老板的程序员都明白那是什么感觉：当那位啥都不懂的老板走进来，开始教你如何编程、如何写代码，
你会怎么做？你会闷闷不乐，写出更烂的代码。如果强迫你违背自己的判断做事，智能体不也一样吗？实际上，我反驳自己一下，我发现现在真正在培养的技能——
大概也是大家共同追求的，就是不过度细化规格，放手让系统自己发挥，只需提供高层次的愿景和指引即可。
甚至更好，因为你连那个都不需要。现代软件开发的基本洞察源自90年代末、21世纪初的敏捷软件开发运动。一群聪明、诚实且勇敢的人聚在一起
他们说，过去四五十年我们尝试的软件开发方式没有成功，也不会成功。我们一直试图预先明确软件应该是什么样子。我们以为可以问人们想要什么，
把需求写下来，用系统思维和严谨性制定规格说明书，然后交给程序员去实现，大家都满意。但结果呢？没有人满意。
因为没有人知道自己想要什么，直到他们得到它。在你摆弄一个程序之前，你不知道它应该做什么。所以在智能体时代，你要抵制一开始就过度具体化的诱惑。尽量模糊地去呈现一些东西，
然后与那个东西互动。你写好软件的方式是，先写一点软件，然后尝试使用它。正是在使用软件的过程中，你才发现你真正想要的是什么。
正是在使用中你发现什么重要、什么不重要。而智能体非常擅长让你在摸索中体验到自己想要什么，因为你其实不知道自己想要什么。
而且我实际上做过一些类似你建议的事情：实现不同的设计、完全不同的实现，然后为自己创建HTML页面、PHP页面，我可以在上面投票，看我更喜欢哪个。
等等，它就这样迭代，非常愉快和有趣。与智能体系统互动，如果你为自己创造一个友好的界面，那会非常有趣，而且你专注于设计部分和
设计中最有趣的部分。
没错。这正是人类真正擅长的。
是啊，品味。
差异性评估。你给我三个选项，我选一个。实际上，如果你给人类22个选项，他们会崩溃。这就是选择的悖论。但给他们三个选项，他们很快就，几乎在
瞬间就能告诉你他们喜欢什么。有很多方法可以利用人类会做出这种快速的、其实是先于理智的判断这一事实，对吧？这些判断来自直觉，然后到达大脑，大脑试图为直觉所说的话找理由。
如果你愿意放下一些理智上的预处理和合理化，让直觉来引导，智能体时代将是一次启示。